bueno
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa instagram enfrenta
una creciente presión para que desista
de sus planes de crear una versión para
niños de su famosa aplicación de
fotografías expertos en el tema se han
opuesto al proyecto argumentando que
afectaría la salud mental y emocional de
los menores y además comprometería su
seguridad y privacidad cuál es la
intención de la compañía en que basan
sus argumentos los detractores de esta
propuesta y sobre todo qué opinan los
padres de familia empezamos
facebook está nuevamente en el ojo del
huracán ahora por la eventual creación
de una versión de su plataforma
instagram para niños menores de 13 años
a principios de marzo la empresa
estadounidense de medios bass fit reveló
que había tenido acceso a información
interna de instagram en la que anunciaba
su intención de crear este producto las
políticas de esta compañía prohíben que
niños menores de 13 años creen una
cuenta en la plataforma y establece que
las cuentas que representen a menores de
13 años deben especificar que están
siendo manejadas por un adulto sin
embargo según reportó bass feet news el
director de instagram adamo serie dijo
que cada vez más niños quieren usar este
tipo de aplicaciones y reconoció que
verificar la edad de los usuarios era un
desafío agregó que parte de la solución
era crear una versión para niños donde
los padres tengan transparencia o
control los niños preguntan cada vez más
a sus padres si pueden unirse a
aplicaciones que les ayuden a mantenerse
al día con sus amigos una versión de
instagram donde los padres tienen el
control como lo hicimos nosotros con
messenger kids es algo que estamos
explorando compartiremos más en el
futuro
pero la idea de crear un instagram para
niños aunque vaya a ser supervisado por
sus padres no convenció a una serie de
funcionarios públicos y activistas que
han instado a facebook a desistir de
este proyecto argumentando que sería
perjudicial para la salud física y
mental la privacidad y la seguridad de
los menores citaron diversos estudios
que demuestran el impacto negativo que
tiene el uso de redes sociales en el
bienestar de los jóvenes y encuestas
como la publicada en 2018 por el centro
de investigaciones pew que arrojó que el
59% de los adolescentes en eeuu sufrió
algún tipo de ciberacoso a través de una
coalición internacional de más de 100
expertos activistas y organizaciones la
campaña por una infancia sí comercial
envió una carta al presidente de
facebook mark zuckerberg lo mismo
hicieron de forma conjunta 40 fiscales
generales de eeuu y más recientemente se
sumó al llamado un grupo de legisladores
demócratas todos coincidieron señalando
al gigante de las redes sociales de
haber fallado en el pasado en su intento
por proteger a los menores que usan sus
aplicaciones
el enfoque incesante de la plataforma en
la apariencia la autopresentación y la
marca presenta desafíos para la
privacidad y el bienestar de los
adolescentes los niños más pequeños
están aún menos preparados para
enfrentar estos desafíos parece que
facebook no está respondiendo a una
necesidad sino que está creando una ya
que esta plataforma trae principalmente
a los niños que de otra manera no tienen
o no tendrían una cuenta de instagram y
es que el rechazo hacia el proyecto de
facebook está fundamentado en una serie
de incidentes que se han presentado en
aplicaciones que fueron adaptadas para
niños en 2017 facebook lanzó la versión
de messenger para menores a través de la
que éstos sólo podrían chatear con
usuarios aprobados por sus padres pero
en 2019 se descubrió una falla que
permitía a los niños entrar a chats
grupales con extraños que no habían sido
autorizados la compañía luego dijo haber
solucionado el error otro que estuvo
bajo la mira fue youtube kits después de
su lanzamiento en 2015 surgieron
críticas sobre la imposibilidad de
desactivar su sistema de reproducción
automática y se presentaron casos en los
que niños se vieron expuestos a
contenidos
no aptos para su edad que pudieron
llegar a la pantalla evadiendo los
filtros de la aplicación linda patiño es
analista digital y también es madre a
ella le consultamos su opinión sobre la
inclusión de menores de 13 años en este
tipo de aplicaciones yo creo que
cualquier padre desea que la virtualidad
de sus hijos sea responsable o lo pasa
es que nadie nace con un manual de
internet debajo del brazo y muchas veces
es complejo
como padres saber cuando estamos
haciendo algo correctamente en internet
yo personalmente creo que está bien que
existan espacios online para niños
pensados para niños para el gran
problema en las redes sociales es que
son un espacio abierto de interacción en
el que no necesariamente todos los
padres nos sentimos cómodos para que
estén desde muy temprana el gran
problema que tenemos es que no hay
ningún sistema que sea 100% fiable y
técnicamente es imposible que exista
porque siempre hay decir en el mundo de
la ciudad de seguridad no hay nada 100%
seguro el que lo diga es porque está
mintiendo el problema es que nadie
quiere que sus hijos sean ratones de
laboratorio para estudiar pero tampoco
nadie quiere que las nuevas
generaciones simplemente nazcan sin
internet y que no puedan aprovechar sus
opciones yo creo que aquí el tema es por
un lado el trabajo de las aplicaciones
buscando entornos cada vez más seguros
pero también está el esfuerzo de
nosotros como padres o como docentes de
acompañar a esos niños no se trata de
darles youtube como niñera se trata de
precisamente que vista en internet hoy
porque lo viste qué opinas que piensas
que no te gustó que te gustó veamos
ahora cómo registran los medios de
comunicación el proyecto de instagram
para crear una versión para niños en
reino unido- el portal de noticias the
guardian titula instagram para niños el
sitio de redes sociales que nadie pidió
y vice news en australia dice puede que
llegue instagram para niños pero los
expertos en salud pública quieren
presionar el botón de pausa el sitio web
de noticias tecnológicas ricou de la
empresa box titula parece que todo el
mundo odia instagram para niños en su
editorial del washington post cuestiona
instagram para niños facebook debería
andar con cuidado el 'new york post'
también dedicó una editorial
al tema y dice que con instagram kids
porque está construyendo un patio de
recreo para pervertidos hasta aquí
revista digital recuerde que si quiere
repetir esta u otra misión de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer a través de
nuestra página web www puntos france24
puntocom
[Música]